netflix has been ramping up its crime
shows in the last few years
especially with the return of unsolved
mysteries recently it released a new
show called crime scene on february 11
2021. the first season is a four-part
series that covers the disappearance of
elisa lam
at the cecil hotel in los angeles the
series did a great job covering the case
from start to end
examining every detail and entertaining
every theory
ultimately using an occam's razor
approach eyewitness accounts and
forensic findings the show gives a
heavily supported conclusion of what
exactly happened to lam the night she
disappeared
we know the details of how elisa lam got
into the tank
and her condition after she was
discovered however we don't know how
long she was alive in the tank 4.
could she have been alive for several
hours or even days
her autopsy report lists the cause of
death as drowning
yet the forensic pathologist who did the
autopsy noted there was no water in her
lungs
or really any sign of drowning so how
did elisa lam really die
what if we look at other things besides
her autopsy one variable that appears to
be overlooked was the temperature
outside the night she died
the conditions in los angeles during
february a winter month has a major role
to play
specifically in hypothermia at first you
may think it's grasping at straws but
upon closer examination
it's truly not and i'll explain why
winter in los angeles is not brutally
cold like winter is in north dakota or
minnesota they're fairly mild with high
60s and low 70s in the day and mid to
low 50s
at night these are not conditions for
frostbite but
if you were in water outside hypothermia
is a reality
hypothermia hypo meaning under and
thermia meaning heat
is excessive heat loss from the body
conditions are somewhat specific and
require two factors
the victim must be wet usually in a body
of water or in the rain
and the temperature must be cool or cold
these are crucial conditions
because the body needs to have heat
removed from it at a constant rate and
water does this extremely well you can
be wet in 85 degree weather
or dry in 60 degree weather and be fine
however if you're soaking wet in 60
degree weather
you're getting hypothermia if we look at
weather records on the night that elisa
lam disappeared
we see the temperature was 54 degrees
fahrenheit this is known because the
elevator footage that recorded her was
from february 1st
it's known to be nighttime for a couple
of reasons first off
lamb was scheduled to check out on
february 1st however she had no baggage
with her so she was not on her way to
the lobby
this would indicate it was actually the
early morning of february 1st
between roughly 12 and 6am no other
guests reported seeing her on the first
because it was the early morning and
most were asleep
finally elisa lam was in a hallucinating
and paranoid state
so it would make sense that she would
not be sleeping but instead wandering
the hotel
just ask any person with paranoia she
entered the elevator from the 14th floor
because perhaps she couldn't sleep
so she decided to get a view from the
top floor paranoia and hallucinations
drove her to the roof
where she made her way to the water tank
and lowered herself in
perhaps she thought it was empty but who
really knows
once in the 54 degree water it began to
act as a heat sink
pulling away her body heat until there
was none left
hypothermia progresses in three stages
mild
moderate and severe each with a lower
body temperature than the last
and increasingly dangerous effects on
the body within a few minutes of being
in the water
lam would have experienced mild
hypothermia her body temperature would
have dropped to about 95 degrees
fahrenheit
and would have tried to mitigate the
heat loss by increasing muscle
contractions
this includes rapid breathing increased
heart rate constriction of blood vessels
and violent shivering in skeletal muscle
her neurological signs would have
remained unaffected within 15 to 20
minutes her body temperature would have
dropped to 90 degrees fahrenheit
now moderate hypothermia sets in the
water is such a powerful heat sink that
body heat is lost faster than it's
produced
muscles begin to lose their
contractility and flexibility due to a
colder body temperature
and reduce circulation as a result
breathing and shivering begin to slow
down as well
the heart undergoes arrhythmia or
abnormal beating and blood begins to
clot in small quantities with less
circulation
less oxygen reaches the brain causing
neurological deficits
such as delirium confusion and fatigue
in the final stage of hypothermia the
body temperature drops to 86 degrees
fahrenheit
coughing and gag reflexes are
non-existent muscles have become rigid
heart rate starts to drop and the skin
turns blue due to low circulation
lack of oxygen to the brain exacerbates
mental fatigue delusions
and confusion at this stage many people
undergo
paradoxical undressing where despite
their fatally low body temperature
they undress themselves it's believed
due to confused signaling they perceive
they are uncomfortably warm and remove
their clothes to cool down
eventually the heart stops beating
breathing ceases and the victim perishes
the amount of time elisa lam was alive
is related to the temperature of the
water she was in
passengers on the titanic who waited in
28 degree water
died of hypothermia within 15 to 30
minutes
people have been known to die of
hypothermia in 50 degree
water in as little as one hour given
that she had no insulated clothing
and at one point became nude would have
made one to two hours
very likely her autopsy ruled the cause
of death as drowning
however it's very likely she died of
hypothermia instead
again the pathologist found little to no
water in her lungs
if someone drowns it's because they're
under water and cannot breathe
at some point water would fill the lungs
however if you're in say neck deep water
that is 50 degrees and you can't get out
of it
you're going to die of hypothermia this
was a very high profile case
and would be met with close scrutiny if
it wasn't fitting optically drowning is
understood more readily by the public
than hypothermia
and optically it's accepted after all
she was trapped in a tank of water what
else would you expect
all in all the cause of death being
drowning instead of hypothermia does not
change the facts or outcome of the case
elisa lam still had a paranoid and
hallucinating episode
causing her to act irrationally and
enter a water tank resulting in her
being trapped and subsequently dying